So now, let's consider division. I know division is the inverse of
multiplication. So it should also take higher priority over addition and
subtraction. So we know in our hierarchy of the order of operations,
multiplication and division should come first. Let's consider this problem:
negative 3 plus 24, divided by 4 times 3. Here are the two expressions that I
could write. This first expression has the parentheses around the 24 and the 4.
The second one has parentheses around the 4 and the 3. In this problem it's
unclear whether or not we're dividing just by 4, or dividing by 4 times 3. We
assume that this is true whenever we see the division symbol without
parentheses. The number immediately after it is included or divided into the
number before it. So, there's no need to solve this problem. Here's one other
word of caution. Whenever we think about simplifying this expression, we don't
actually want to use PEMDAS. If you've heard of PEMDAS, then you probably
remember that multiplication comes before division. But, this is not necessarily
true. Multiplication and division have the same priority whenever we do the
order of operations. Students who learn that multiplication comes first using
PEMDAS would be incorrect. We know we should carry out this division before we
do the multiplication. In general, we should think about doing our
simplification from left to right, because multiplication and division have the
same priority in the order of operations. So these parentheses are assumed to be
the case, so let's evaluate this expression. I have -3 plus 6 times 3. And
negative 3 plus 18. Negative 3 plus 18 makes 15. In doing our order of
operations, it's important to remember the hierarchy. That multiplication and
division have the same priority and should be done from left to right in the
order of operation.